jessica is with us in Houston Texas hi
Jessica how are you hi they think you
were taking my call sure what's up well
Arthur Joyce is that my husband and I
have been married for five months and
we're trying to decide if it's the right
time to buy a house so we currently rent
a tiny one-bedroom apartment for like
six hundred a month and just so like
we're throwing away this money every
month I've never borrowed money for
anything and that's why we came to the
marriage with the plan of buying a house
cash but maybe a mortgage makes more
sense in the situation I just don't know
what's the big reward of those throwing
money on rent or pay it interest rate
well if money if rent is a way of life
throughout your entire life yes you're
throwing money away if it is patience
while you're waiting to do a wise thing
then it's not throwing it away
you're just paying for patience a little
bit now so let's talk it through what is
your household income about eighty-five
thousand years phenomenal and you have
zero dad they wrote that and how much
have you saved during the five months
well we've saved twenty thousand in the
five months but I came into the marriage
with a hundred so now we have one
hundred and twenty thousand okay and you
live in Houston Texas
yeah and so if you waited another five
months you'd have a hundred and forty
thousand yes that's what we're
projecting pretty easily yeah okay
probably more actually but well I mean
what can you buy for a hundred and fifty
grand
I'm a lot more than a lot more than
you're living in right now yeah
definitely you probably can't buy a lot
more than we live in a like a hundred
thousand I don't know if we should just
buy that and it's to be smaller but or
if we should just go ahead and buy
something we can grow into my phone we
start having kids and well I mean you
can move yeah that's true you know you
could buy something and then two years
from now sell it and move up and buy
then you would have saved another fifty
or hundred thousand bucks probably well
you I mean you don't even rent that way
so you'd have a lot maybe even more some
if you bought something for a hundred
now two years later you could buy
something for 200 yeah so that's that's
what we're thinking we don't know if
it's better just to keep saving and
pay the rent or just buy something small
now and you throw it you threw out a
mortgage I don't think a mortgage is
necessary okay here's here's kind of
your balance all right um number one I
don't think you need a mortgage because
you have done so well I mean you were
dadgum financial rock stars you're
amazing what you've done how old are you
I'm 26 and 1030 you've done extremely
well very well so to start with let's
just say that you're in the top 1% out
there of smart people with money I mean
you're really doing good so what would I
do if I woke up in your shoes you've
been married five months I would
probably wait until next spring okay at
that point you will have been married a
year and I would buy something with in
the cash that you have by then okay what
you're going to have 100 you have a
hundred and fifty plus by then yeah and
I'm going to buy something for that and
that gets me out of the one bedroom and
it if I know I've got a deadline I can I
can hold my nose a little better with
the one bedroom yeah it's just hard also
knowing that you can you basically spend
all that money out and you're not
getting anything back you are you're
getting patience you're getting patience
you're just a tightwad I love you you're
awesome
and so yeah that's probably what I would
do and then I would keep saving like a
maniac and plan to move up a hundred
grand a year or two from now a couple of
years from now and then you may do it
again there's nothing wrong with you can
just keep doing that perpetually do you
live in a million-dollar paid-for house
you know if you move up a hundred grand
every two years that doesn't take but a
few years to do that
Plus these houses are going to be going
up in value while you own them so that's
other thing that sounds like you again
to have now knowing that that's going to
go up in value in your Dom you got time
okay so the second reason I'm telling
you wait till next spring is a good rule
of thumb if you're if you're married
your first marriage on you're under 30
is to spend a year being married to get
to know each other before you buy a
house together okay and you'll but
you'll make a wiser house purchase after
a year of marriage because you will have
ironed out the wrinkles of the first
year first year is always kind of fun
and it's also got its own little special
problems and so you know you get that
stuff figured out I always the way I
laughingly say it is it takes a year of
being married to know how close to your
mother-in-law to buy yes you know you
don't want to hang curtains together do
you been married a year you know it's
enough to cause a divorce right there so
you know these are just funny things but
they kind of indicate what I'm talking
about and so I love for you to just
concentrate on your marriage and saving
and have a goal okay when the weather
breaks next spring we're going to start
looking and you know set your lease up
when's your lease up we actually don't
have a leak okay then you're fine so you
can just set it up and say okay in
February we're going to start looking
and we're probably moving into our new
place in March or April because that's
going to be your next spring in Houston
right yeah that's fine and you're going
to be able to save it on a money by then
and then you kind of smile and go hey
let's make a game out of it how much
money can we save may we get 175,000 on
our house next spring you know I don't
know you guys make you make good money
you got no bills and you are tightwads
you're awesome you're just absolutely
impressive so that's what I would do if
I woke up in your shoes I would pay cash
for whatever I did now if you want to
jump the gun and do it right now I think
you might make an error but I don't
think it's a death error I don't think
it's going to kill you but if you do pay
cash for whatever you do because you're
in a position to move into something
nicer than you live in today and pay
cash for it it puts you in exactly that
situation so a good question thank you
for joining us hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you're enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right kind of better
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about rice and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you